welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed greg
hurwitz
greg's a family friend from when my dad
worked at harvard
i really like greg he writes thrillers
that i think should be movies
we covered how to write thrillers his
newest book
prodigal son the orphan acts series is
my favorite
thriller series hands down if you need
some
somewhat stressful reading it's kind of
like the bourne series except
i like it better we also covered some
family stories from the past
i was written into one of his graphic
novels in a hilariously unfavorable way
when i was a child
and we touched a bit on how he's been an
influence in helping the democratic
party
in the u.s work on their storytelling
and narrative through commercials and
political ads
dun dun dun i know the majority of you
folks are republicans but you should
listen anyway to get the inside scoop
i don't really have faith in any type of
government to be honest given the fact
i'm currently in canada and nothing's
been open for two months
also we ran out of vaccines so i just
hate
everyone really i thought what greg said
about the democratic party was
interesting though
hope you liked this episode this episode
is brought to you by true local
true local is the company i get my meat
from i'm super picky about the quality
of what i eat because if you only eat
one thing
although technically i eat more than one
thing i eat fish too now and some
chicken
anyway if you only eat meat and it
doesn't taste good
life would be very difficult you can go
to trulocal.ca to make yourself a custom
box they have any meat you want plus
some organs
i like their grain-fed beef lamb turkey
and wild salmon
but i haven't tried any of the spiced
meat or pork you can also get some
vegetables on there now too
they connect with local farmers and then
ship you their products
so it's really simple for you and it's
great for keeping local farmers working
and getting people access to high
quality sustainably raised meat
trulocal.ca codemp
for free stakes and so mark from 2local
knows their investment into my podcast
is worth it
if you like this episode please remember
to subscribe
[Music]
craig hurwitz welcome to my podcast good
to see you mick
can we start off by you giving my
audience a brief background about who
you are and what it is that you do
yeah i'm uh i'm a novelist i write
primarily
thrillers uh that's always been my love
my latest series is called orphan acts
there's six of them the six in the
series
just released and i've also done some
television
uh movies and i've written comics i
wrote batman for a couple years for dc
i've written wolverine punisher
and that's where it is that's where it
started i've branched out a bit into
some political and cultural commentary
mostly focusing on depolarization
what have you been you i'd like i think
you've been doing it
for a number of years and you said it
was to make things
just do you do it i'm doing a bad job
right well i started to delve into
politics to try to help
the democrats with storytelling um
the democrats are the party that i'd
long belong to and when donald trump was
elected the first question i asked
myself was
um i was i'm not a fan was not a fan of
president trump
and so i wanted to figure out how to
wade into the political conversation
which is uh treacherous and arrogant
right if you're outside of it and so i
thought that the best way to start would
be to say
what are all the things that we're
getting wrong that made someone like him
more palatable than most americans
and i sort of went down that rabbit hole
and tried to think about
um storytelling and values that the
party had strayed from
um and i wound up doing a lot of
advising um
you know sort of gearing uh the
messaging
and and and the platform even in some
regards because the messaging works it
can start to shift the platform back to
a more moderate
moderate center which is actually i
think where most of the party lives as
opposed to the voices that get the most
oxygen
and so i spent a lot of years doing that
in terms of really
mostly good faith efforts to try and
reach out and have
conversations the way we used to right
you're voting for one person
i think another person is better let's
talk about your values and let's talk
about ways that we can frame and
and have good faith outreach
to try and talk to you and figure that
out differently and so we did a lot of
just a ton of outreach i did about 200
commercials we work with about 90
candidates at the midterm cycle and
later
work with some um uh colleagues of mine
out here
um and a lot of it is my my the end goal
or the uber goal
is anti-polarization even though i come
you know i come in from kind of center
left i've done some overlap with your
dad who comes in kind of center right
we in fact did an event at the capitol
where i brought 10
uh democratic reps and we brought in
through
for your dad and some other uh
associates of his
10 republican reps to just sit down and
start to talk about why they first got
into politics what was their motivation
right what were their what was their
value set we said let's not talk about
policy let's talk about anything
contemporary
let's just try and stitch some of this
fabric back together again
because i think it's essential and so
you know i've been doing that a lot it's
always fun being anywhere in
in towards the middle right so i'm i'm
center
i'd say center left center tilting
liberal
because of course you know you it's
tricky you're the the
i'm always trying to impact the actual
outcome the arguments don't interest me
the screaming doesn't interest me
um what interests me is how do we
actually try to make things better how
do we get legislation
passed that has any affiliation with
what voters want the
odds just to give you one example um the
percent of americans who agree with a
law getting passed or deem it important
has zero percent correlation with
whether that law will pass
zero yeah that's screwed up and so
a lot of it for me was trying to get
down the real baseline
and going look let's forget sort of you
know
this the screaming about political
leaders and the cultural conversation
all that how do we get down
to those things and figure out like how
far down do we have to go
to agree on something that we can
actually get something done and so
you know that's been a lot of what my
work has been i don't claim to have done
it perfectly it's a
it's a giant um treacherous confusing
mess but i went out and sort of talked
to
i did my best to talk to everyone around
the political wheel
you know i'll sit down and talk to
anybody whether i agree with them or not
um and so i kind of went out and talked
to everyone from
you know military evangelicals black
lives matter leadership
um actually talked to some people
actually in the alt-right as opposed to
everyone who gets described as being an
all-right
who largely aren't in the media um
you know republicans democrats i wanted
to talk to
you know white suburban housewives in
ohio and michigan
right um we reached out any slice in any
demographic anywhere around the wheel
and i wanted to really
understand what they thought and where
they were
you know on the supposition that i don't
think anyone should be so arrogant as to
try and change someone's mind if they
don't
understand where they're coming from
first and in a few instances people are
very extreme on the right or the left
and they can't be um
their goal is to do more damage and to
collect more power on the basis of
division if that's truly their goal
i want to talk to them anyways because
you should know your enemy and if
they're the enemy of more progress for
more people in a direction i think
that's important
you know i didn't mind having those
conversations but that
you know a lot of that's coming from
writing books you know when i write
characters i'm trying to
sort of pull on the the mask of the
character and see the world through
their eye holes
so i've talked to you know cops and
professors and porn stars and snipers
and i'll talk to anybody right
i talk to criminals i talk to former
spies and so
trying to talk to people to understand
how they think is something that's
i've always just been really curious
about and i think that piece of it
served me well
uh you know served me mostly well when
it came to
entering into the political and cultural
fray
that sounds like a lot of work uh that's
a that's a lot of research
it's interesting because i've been i've
been
i've taken those internet tests i'm like
where do i lie on the political spectrum
and according to the internet tests
whatever those are worth i'm like just
right of center which is probably around
where dad is although i don't
that's hard to be hard for me to wrap my
mind around because like
how can some of the things i stand for
be put
put in the more conservative category
but regardless one of the questions i
wanted to ask was
utersines are complicated though because
it's funny because you have a strong
there's a strong conservative center
right basis and then you guys also have
like a strong hippie streak in the
family
and so it's like it's this funny thing
you know that
i dedicated troubleshooter one of my
books to your dad
and i was talking about the different
parts uh of him and one of them is he's
you know he's got a streak that's like
an outlaw biker you know
and so it's funny because there's the
conservatism but there's also a strong
hippie slash renegade streak that and
high openness that's conventionally more
more liberal so yeah like like most
people
who are interesting and not neatly
slotted
you know it should be a bit messy it
shouldn't just be that you
you know most people i think don't line
up with everything in one direction or
another
and if they do if they come right down
on some sort of a party line
they tend to not be very interesting to
talk to because then you know all their
opinions
right and they're not tackling your
opinions from different angles in ways
yeah that's true if if somebody has one
opinion on one subject and then you can
accurately judge
where their opinion lies on every other
subject then
that's not that's not that much fun
do you think okay here's another one um
so you've been you've been working
trying to
at least figure out the issues that
people are having on both
sides on both like of the extremes um do
you think
things are going in the right direction
because in my opinion
i mean kovid just screwed everything up
and everyone's locked down and so it's
hard to say
what kind of role what what kind of
effect that's going to have
and what effect what and if the
government is behind
some of the problems it's caused like
the lockdown which i think is ridiculous
but
but anyway do you think that things are
going in
an okay direction do you think that
we're coming back together or do you
think that
like i know that conservatives are
pretty upset that trump didn't win and
they don't really know what to do with
themselves
well and they're not like a lot of
people i know they're not going to be
like oh biden
binds the guy now so do you think that
we're going to get back together or are
we still going in kind of opposite
directions for a while
i think you know i have a slightly
different view of all this and that i
think that
i think we're finally getting to a lot
of what's real and a lot of what's real
is really ugly um a lot of the
stuff that we talk about racism and
gender i think are sort of like surface
issues
in a lot of ways that take up the most
oxygen
but beneath the tectonics there's stuff
like the prison industrial complex
that's just unconscionable that i
think most um conservatives and even you
know
mega trump supporters if that was
spelled out in clear terms
would understand as problematic i think
that you know we've seen
50 trillion dollars with a t migrate
from the bottom
90 to the top 1 in the last 40 years
some of that has to do with globalism
but some of that has to do with
you know lobbyists writing laws
literally for congress i mean
the corruption baked into the system
is really overwhelming um and so there's
a lot of problems that i think are
significant that we
have to contend with um and i don't
think we'd be contending with them if we
were say
two weeks into hillary clinton's second
term i think we would have been on that
same trajectory
when we talk about that movement of 50
trillion dollars from the bottom 90 to
the top one by the way
you know much of it not through free
market capitalism much of that's not
driven by innovation and competition
that was under obama that was under
clinton also right that's like reagan
bush obama clinton
and so i think in some ways that the
mess that we've seen
and the explosion of discussion around
corruption and race and all these other
things
it's this is sort of like america's
descent to the underworld it's like
things get worse before they get better
in anything in a thriller in therapy
it's not like you go into therapy and
just start fixing things right you go in
if you're going into therapy in good
nature
everything gets worse you go backwards
and you go down and you go in
and i think that america is in a process
of reckoning right now there's a lot of
um excesses that we've seen from
extremes there's a lot of damage that's
been caused
a lot of i think our cultural quarreling
is happening as a distraction for the
migration of bigger monies to be moving
um in a certain direction and so i think
it's really up to us at this point to
decide
you know we're having different
conversations a lot of the toxins are
closer to the surface
can we go in and address them in real
ways real ways not being socialism
railways not being authoritarianism
right
not being the things that are offered by
the polls or the
the the extreme polls but if we can
address them in ways that are real and
earnest
maybe they won't go underground like a
lot went underground after the 60s again
right and we'll just deal with it in
worse fashion
moving forward and so i think you know
part of what i'm
i'm hopeful about is that we can we can
stop we can stop
only tilting towards the extremes and in
group warfare and in group definition
and in group um you know unfriending
everyone who disagrees with us all that
other stuff
it's we've gotten so polarized it's it's
just it's incredible and i've i've spent
the better part of four years out kind
of in that no man's land in the middle
um you know where where some of us
live and try to discuss to change things
and the more people that join there
the better the more people who will go
yeah i don't socialism isn't an answer
for anything and neither is a
you know authoritarianism clear let's
just get clear on that and start talking
about real stuff
instead of perennial outrage cycles we
can start moving that way
and i think that's our job so all we can
do
is try to try and open that up for
people as best we can
in the little ways that we can
yeah well i hope you're right i wouldn't
i would
be upset if things keep getting more
divisive
that would be really sad because america
is really cool
canada's really cool it'd be like even
the last couple of years
um seeing everything become so
divisive well it's so much it's so
joyless and it's so sexless
and it's so without adventure i mean
some of the the best
adventures and conversations and
experiences i have
people who are so different from me you
know and i think
the more that we lock into these sort of
prim warlike positions
the less we get the further we get from
the joy of this
you know and all the positives there's
so many positives to dealing with
you know different you know one of the
things i talk about with liberals
is we tend to be really good at
idolizing or being open to other
societies or cultures as long as they're
removed but it's harder for us when
there's a culture within america that
feels really different
right a culture that involves you know
hunting and religion and different
things it's too close to home right but
if you're dealing with
you know the yamamoto tribe or something
else then then there's there's a lot of
openness
and so a lot of the work that i was
doing was trying to find like where are
those shared values if we're just
screaming about climate change and
environmentalism on the surface or can
we go down and talk to people in
communities and go
you know clean uh fields and streams
are important obviously you fish you
live on the land you farm right like
like what are the ways we can get back
to seeing how these
like different cultures different values
and different lifestyles
are um rich and filled with their own
experiences and adventures and if we can
just take a little bit of time to get
further down to something that is shared
we can then start to build on that
you know you can't do it with people who
have been radicalized you just can't
um but there's a lot more room to get
back to the color and life that's
offered
with a huge real diversity of people
because we got we got plenty of
different cultures and subcultures in
america and canada
um and a lot of them are you know we
don't
we don't when it feels prescribed either
prescribed or bellicose
we lose sight of what how much fun and
what an adventure it can be
to engage with different groups and go
and have different experiences
yeah it's tricky with social media
especially because you get in these
groups of people that agree with you and
then
you're like oh this is like my people
but i i guess
what i try and do is if i'm around
people
and we all have exactly the same
thoughts about something for a while
i'll tune into that and be like okay i
just have to do a little bit of research
into the other people just just in case
i'm getting
like pigeonholed into something because
it's really easy especially with all the
isolation we're experiencing now
and with social media so if you're
around a whole bunch of people
you could be in the right too i'm not
saying you're in the wrong but if you're
around a whole bunch of people and they
all agree with exactly what you're
saying it's good to just remember to
reach out a couple of times to talk to
people who don't agree
just to see where they're coming from
with a bit of an open mind to be like
maybe there's something here i could be
wrong
yeah yeah i think that's a great idea
and the other thing is is let's say that
your group of people
all are in agreement that there is a
problem then it's also if you have to
figure out how to fix the problem
and actually do something about it
that's another way that you have to open
up to a bunch of new data
right because often even if you agree
that something isn't functioning and
this happened to me time and time and
time again
in my forays into politics or into
culture
the process of even if i'm pretty sure
that my belief structure is one that i
want to hold on to
when you go to fix it all sorts of new
information floods in
and the solutions are are never easy and
so i think it's either reaching out to
people who disagree
or moving towards trying to actually fix
or do something because then
then ideology is just out the window
you're just trying to fix something
so how do you actually do it in a way
that's right
although although that could also be
taken in a way that
if you see a problem in society maybe
that would encourage people to take to
the streets to fix it
because then where do you draw the line
about how to fix something
that's another tricky subject politics
are tricky i don't even like them i
don't know why i bring them up
okay this is prodigal son
this so i don't read any fiction
um i all i read is non-fiction
for you know podcast guests i haven't
read
for fun in so long however
i do read these greg has
absolutely fantastic thrillers that are
kind of like
um born novels that's what they kind of
remind me of they're very exciting
so i haven't read this one yet but i'm
going to
i think i'm actually how many are in
this series
there's seven six so far this is the sex
oh well then maybe i'm caught up
actually okay good i thought there were
seven
okay excellent anyway i would highly
recommend if people need
like a fairly stressful beach fiction
there's murder is great murder intrigued
mayhem
yeah uh and you also did in the
background i can see you have batman
there
you did a lot of graphic novel writing
right
yeah i branched out so i started with
novels um i started my first book i was
still in college my manuscript i wrote
a profoundly awful draft the summers
before and after my senior year which i
then edited furiously
and then i added feature films uh tv and
then comics
comics i started at marvel my favorite
character growing up was the punisher i
was obsessed with the punisher
from seventh grade on and i got a call
from the
uh editor-in-chief of marvel who kind of
said look you can pick any
character out of the marvel vaults that
you want and
you know and so it was my internal
nerd boy was doing cartwheels but i was
acting very professional
and so i wrote a run on the punisher
after garth ennis's
legendary run and it was this very
surreal experience for me because i
remember i was i was down at comic-con
and everyone's sort of selling the
punisher and i no longer
could buy my favorite comic book that
i've been reading forever because i'd
written it and i already knew what
happened
so that was my point of entry and then i
wrote a bit of
wolverine and then i had a meeting over
at um
with dc and they sort of um lured me
over
to the other side and so i wound up
writing batman for a couple years
is comic-con completely full of nerds
i really want to go you would love
comic-con it's very much your speed i
mean
it's it's changed really drastically it
used to be
a lot more conventional nerd focused
um but as that you know nerd has become
something now that it's cool like the
all the definitions
have been inverted there's a big
hollywood presence now i mean so there's
a whole section on this
of course it feels a bit like work for
me it feels like the hollywood side of
it
but i love that like the old collectible
comics
the places that sell the old art there's
there's a lot of quirky stuff still on
the comic side that's just
terrific um so it's just a lot of fun to
go and and wander around
and um you would love it
i've been wonder woman for actually i
wasn't wonder woman last halloween i was
a lobster
but every year before that since the age
of 17 i was wonder woman
so i'm
sounds like cheating that's very
familiarly
thematic nick
yeah it was a spur of the moment
decision and then i was like i'll just
make a contest and see if anyone else
will be a lobster and a whole bunch of
other people
also dressed up as lobsters and i was
just like
this is hilarious this can trump my
wonder woman outfit
uh it was it was it was pretty fun okay
so let's start
let's start with the questions um how do
you write
how do you come up with the ideas behind
your books because
writing non-fiction is one thing you can
do research you can write a memoir
it's stuff that's or i guess you can you
know dad's book would be considered
non-fiction and that's
there's a lot of thought that went into
that but
i i'm so fascinated at how people can
come up with these universes
that don't exist so how do you do it and
where do you start
well my head works in stories
i kind of thought everyone's head works
that way there's so much of how we grow
up and we don't notice
it's like the uh we think that
everyone's brains are similar to ours so
i read
non-stop i wasn't allowed to watch
television growing up and i just was
reading constantly and i thought anyone
who loved reading
was interested in creating stories i was
just obsessed with stories from a young
age um
and i think the worst advice that people
give to writers
fiction is write what you know because
it assumes that there's some
bounded range of experience that is what
you know and what you should stick to
and i've always used writing and writing
thrillers
as an excuse for continuing education
almost like i
you know was i was very interested in
mind control cults so i wrote a book
that takes place in mind control cults i
went undercover to mind control cults
i've gone
up in stunt airplanes right to do
research um
i've gone uh i've snuck onto demolition
ranges with seals and blown up trucks i
get on all the weapons that orphanax
shoots and fires with a friend of mine
who was uh
you know a high level material and
weapons expert and sniper and so
you know and and it's it's not all the
the sort of action-y stuff though that's
a key part of it because
what i want to do is give the reader a
front-row seat to the action so whether
that's me observing a corner
like carving or parting up a body um or
going down a class 4
white water rapid run in the jungles of
oaxaca
if i go to do it i can write about it
differently instead of just a
conglomeration of what
other movies and books and tv that we've
seen
um so to give one concrete example
before i started orphan x i did some
mixed martial arts training
by which i don't mean to imply that i
was great at it it was mostly a
process of me introducing my face
repeatedly to the training mat
but in certain choke holds when that was
happening to me there's a there's a
particular feeling
and sensation of getting choked out it's
there's like a claustrophobia there's a
vertiginous kind of horror and if i was
experiencing that
and sensing it i can write about it
differently as opposed to a lot of
thrillers
or mysteries when someone gets knocked
out will say you know and then he saw
black right there's all these cliches
that are relied upon
and so the aim is always to use familiar
words and unfamiliar ways
to bring readers in so that they have a
feeling that that
it's real and so it's really important
for me to go out in the world and
explore that and sometimes that's in an
academic direction talking to a bunch of
professors about
you know geotonic plates and in prodigal
son i dive into
an aspect of military technology so
there's the action and there's there's
the other end and so each book becomes
like its own
experience for me the ideas and the
engine is the thing that's harder to
describe like why i choose to write
about a particular conflict it usually
comes from something i'm working out
myself
internally okay that makes sense to me
though um
if you go out and experience these
things it's almost like you're
writing a memoir kind of that that
sounds easier to write about than making
up everything like i've always wondered
how
how what's his name george george rr
martin
is that his name wrote game of thrones
like i just don't
i don't understand how you can come up i
mean even with your books
you said you're potentially working
through something internally
uh but it seems like a lot to come up
with an entire world if you have some
experiences to throw in there
that makes sense so i think you know
everything's derived from that i've
written a horror i've written science
fiction also
um you know in terms of screenplays and
i think the key thing is always
we remember character stuff i mean
before i started the orphan x series
i had to give a lot of thought to what
would be
what would make this character worthy of
sitting on the shelves next to james
bond and jason bourne and jack reacher
there's all these great characters
and so a lot of it for me was getting
all the way down and figuring out what
are the things that define him what are
the things that
that make him unique and different
because at the end of the day
if you ask people they all will
people won't all be able to say here's
my favorite action sequence and all the
james bonds but everybody knows how he
how he takes his martini and so the
aspects that give you a hold on
character are important and there's a
couple things
for me with orphan x that were that were
really key and one of them was i wanted
to have this
archetypal character who undertakes
these near impossible missions
but have him live in the real world
where you and i live because we never
get to see
james bond go home or jason bourne get
like pulled into an annoying
homeowner's association meeting when
he's bleeding through his sleeve
to have to have a conversation about the
new carpet in the lobby and so evan
lives among ordinary people because
part of him he was he was raised outside
of society he was raised from the age of
under the tutelage of jack johns um
who was his handler and became like a
father figure to him under these very
rigid
rules the ten assassins commandments you
know how you do anything's how you do
everything
never make it personal and the series is
really about him cracking that open to
try and learn how to interact with other
people
one of the lines i use is to say he did
he doesn't understand the strange
language of intimacy he wasn't raised
with that
so he's trying to figure out how to
engage with real people while even
living in this sort of archetypal world
um and so that's been fun you know the
counterpoint to the 10 assassins
commandments
i wanted something to show what a normal
more healthy
upbringing would be like and there's a
single mother who's a district attorney
who lives downstairs and she has an
eight-year-old boy who haven't has a
relationship with
and her rules that she leaves for peter
her son
are are jordan's 12 rules for life
and it's funny because i started to put
those in you know i like to say back
when jordan was still lower case
jordan peterson instead of all caps
jordan peterson
it was off i think it was the quora
piece yeah yeah
and he was just starting to to write
this book and
you know i was i i had the privilege of
being able to read it early drafts and
and offer some suggestions and other
things and so i just thought some of
those rules
encapsulated that's really the the
sort of healthy path if you're going to
acquaint someone to have a normal
upbringing
like me is trying to do with peter as
opposed to evans where everything is
about you know never kill an innocent
never take two missions at the same time
never make it personal
they're almost the opposite and the
series is about him breaking from
one uh version of himself
and cracking through into a new
understanding and it's just all framed
in a
in a thriller series but it's really
about a transformation of character
you mentioned him going home and his his
wall
his plant wall is something i've tried
to mimic
like from visualizing it from that book
yeah yeah a vertical living garden
um there's only it's very few spots of
color his whole
penthouse is sort of cold like a
mausoleum scandinavian design
his bed is a slab of metal that actually
floats it's propelled by
rare earth magnets so everything's cold
but he has this one spot of color which
is a living wall where herbs are grown
and he uses them mostly as garnish where
he drinks the world's finest vodkas
because the purification and
distillation process of vodka
mimics in some ways what his own
character overwhelmed
underwent to to you know forge himself
into
the finest most distilled version of
himself and so he drinks vodka sometimes
as a bit of a purification ceremony and
that's been wonderful for the author
because all these
distillers from around the world send me
their vodka because
if it appears in the book then people
get excited about it and buy a lot of it
so i have quite an array of good vodkas
at the house
i have a lot of dried meat products
i bet like we could trade that's true
like why didn't i
why didn't i become vodka girl we could
have a
piece next true true
uh you were dad taught
you at harvard right that's how you guys
have the connection
yeah i took a introduction into um
personality psych and then i took a
young seminar from him
and um and then he was my thesis advisor
and so what was interesting was you know
it's funny steve jobs gives us
gave this commencement address at
stanford some years ago where he talks
about you never know the path you're
following
if you're following your passions if it
feels like it doesn't make sense and
then when you look back there's a
perfect pattern to it
and so in college in my studies i was
you know i was very drawn
uh to jordan right away i just took
everything that i could and pulled him
in to be my thesis advisor which there's
a there's a whole bunch of funny stories
about that
um but um we had a really good time but
it's funny because
i study i did for i did shakespearean
tragedy i did
freudian and jungian analysis of
shakespearean tragedy
and so it just was the thing that
interested me the most and of course in
hindsight the shakespearean tragedies
are like these perfect thrillers right
they're tales of lust intrigue and
murder
designed to impact the widest slice of
elizabethan society
right and to put asses and chairs
shakespeare was trying to sell off the
globe he was a commercial
and you know freud's case studies read
like short stories
and in fact he won the nobel in
literature which was sort of an insult
and i didn't know that that is dream
theory and then jung of course
only writes about story and the
underpinnings of stories and so as i was
just following the stuff that was of the
most interest
in hindsight i look back on it and of
course it it all makes perfect sense
that it was driving in this direction of
you know hero's journey thrillers right
crime fiction um it all kind of made
sense
but i it's it's it was kind of um
it's just you know if if you're
fortunate in your life you get to have
a professor or a teacher where their
fields of interest and expertise and
insight just line up
almost exactly with with your own and i
felt that way
you know when i started to take
personality psych and then diving into
young young was like
crack for me i mean it was just it was
like putting voice to everything that i
thought about but explaining it into in
a manner that makes sense to me and in
fact i've credited young
well i credited him he doesn't need any
credit for me but you know i think about
young a lot that
for me it was the best way into some
understanding of spirituality
you know i've born again christian
friends who you know who are
either seals or grew up as sons of
missionaries in china
and you know come from a very strong
spiritual
base and for me young was sort of this
intellectual and story-based way to
drill down to the same
reservoir that is spiritual and so i've
had this really amazing experiences
lately talking to
some of my friends who are pretty devout
christians because
it's almost like with jung i realize
that if you if you overlap the stuff
that i'm figuring out or playing with in
jungian terms there's a real overlap to
them
they just happen to speak jesus right so
it's a the ways that they can overlap
there's so much similarity there and so
young in a lot of ways was more to me
than just
academic or psychology or even about
story it was a way of burrowing down to
a whole other level of meaning
that also let me understand a lot of
people raised different
in different circumstances and different
belief structures than me
that's way beyond where i'm at i need to
podcast less to read more young
or i could just podcast with people who
read young or
that sounds like cheating though eat
meat and drink vodka that's the other
option
that sounds like a good option too meat
and vodka stone
i think last time you were down though
we were on bourbon which is which is
actually my personal preference but
yeah why didn't why didn't you get evan
to drink bourbon
you know if that's that one of those
those issues where
you want everything to be in service to
the story into the character if it was
in service to me it would have been
bourbon i have more bourbon than i have
vodka even
but for him vodka's the purest spirit
and
it's it's what this series is really
about is him
figuring out his way towards the closest
version of sort of balance and purity
and so the purity
that vodka undertakes in the
distillation process
it mirrors his own psychology it mirrors
his own training and so he he drinks it
almost as a purge
you know the second commandment the
second assassin's commandment which is
it tends to be people's favorite which
is really um
interesting is how you do anything is
how you do everything
that's not bent towards perfection um
and i think it's easy to see between
that and the purification of the vodka
and the
the scandinavian cleanliness of his
penthouse apartment with its secret he's
got some secret doors and
has a kind of nerve center with weapons
and and hacking stuff
but it's easy to see that that's sort of
his retreat from all the messiness
of the world of intimacy of human
interaction
and so the vodka plays a key role it's a
purification aspect but that
that that how you do anything is how you
do anything
you can also see how that can lead into
dangerous perfectionism and in fact
evan has uh ocd at times that when he is
stressed or under a lot of threat it
will start to rear its head because he
doesn't know how to turn that off
perfectionism is a very hard trait to
turn off and to know
when it can stop so the second
commandment can get dangerous because
the software in his head can get in a
loop about that
yeah i feel that uh what did you call
his fancy i called it a plant wall and
you're like yes his living
garden it's a living wall or vertical
garden a vertical garden okay
and then i felt like a slob slightly
plant wall mine's a plant wall
i wanna see maybe one day it'll be a
vertical garden
um yeah i saw that uh in a couple
i think i saw that in a restaurant in
hawaii had a beautiful rise
they would pluck things off to service
and i thought how great to have him do
that in the service of
mostly in the service of his vodka
he's very precise about his vodka
okay i want to get to like some
practical questions about writing
and then and then delve into other
things but
how did you choose did you choose a
publishing house and did you choose an
editor like i know who you work with as
an editor is vitally important
so do you have suggestions for people
who are
you know there's always a pull to
self-publish now too
um because you can keep a lot more of
the money but then you might have
problems finding an editor so do you
have
any suggestions for people looking for
publishing houses or
editors and what to look for well i've
always gone the conventional route so i
think my
my advice is is limited about
self-publishing
i mean i was i was pretty fortunate to
to sell my first but the aforementioned
first book with the really shitty rough
drafts that i wrote before and after
my senior year college which i then
revised you know furiously
um and so you know it there's a tricky
balance because at first you just want
you need an agent and you need an editor
and so there's a
there's a power imbalance that really
happens because you're
you're one of you know thousands of
submissions that they're going to get a
year
for the maybe one that they'll take on a
month and so
it's a very steep uphill climb in that
regard but then you know once
once i was established a certain amount
i was able to make moves within
publishing to land with the editors
who were the ones i most wanted to work
with so i'm with penguin random house in
the uk i share a publisher
um with your old man which is funny
because i was downstairs there
uh my last book tour recording something
and i heard a familiar kermit like voice
up the hall
and i went around and bust he was in the
he was recording some podcasts
one studio over it was really fun that's
weird
i opened the door and you could see his
publicist had a moment of like some
deranged
jordan peterson fan breaking in into the
room
it was really funny so then we recorded
something together so we had some
overlap uh
in england which was fun and in the us
i'm with minotaur books
which is under macmillan and the thing
that i've looked for it's a little bit
different i can give some advice to
people starting out
for me what i want in editors are i
don't like yes men or yes women i like
people who are very frank i don't
i don't want a lot of i don't
need a lot of um
you know praise is good encouragement is
great but i want to know what's not
working and why
and people are old-fashioned editors who
um if they don't like something they'll
tell me in plain language and the more
specific they are the more helpful it is
and this is this is a very important
note for anybody who's writing
when people give notes you have to
choose who you're going to listen to
carefully and then you have to listen
those are the rules so people have big
writing groups and everyone's weighing
in
they might see saw you this way and that
and you'll you'll get further away from
your own voice and too much input is bad
if there's someone smart and they
actually know how to edit
then you you don't let go of that and
you listen and it doesn't mean that you
take the edits
literally and so a lot of times like i
learned this a lot when i was dealing
with notes from producers or directors
they'll say for instance like oh this
the script's really lagging right here
in the third act and what you listen to
isn't the specific note
but the underlying editorial anxiety so
a lot of times i'll think huh
that's where you noticed it and wrote it
down but the real problem was in the
second act earlier
right and it bugged you but you only
realized that it felt slow later on
and so when you're listening to people
who you trust they'll be closer to
what the real problem is to being able
to diagnose and put their finger on it
but you want to kind of go beneath the
nose and beneath the specifics and see
what's what's bothering them on a deeper
level and sometimes you have to draw it
out of people it's just like a
conversation
when you have an altercation with a
friend or a spouse or
you know again yeah that's right it's
like there people aren't always saying
exactly what they think it's not like
editors
magically know exactly what they're
thinking they're good at it
but it's important to listen and it's
important to make sure that you're
listening to people who aren't just
going to tell you how great you are
because that doesn't get you far
okay that's very valuable but they don't
always know
i mean you can be skeptical about
everybody but they might have identified
something and they don't exactly know
what that is
that's right and you know you we see
that all the times in all
other kinds of communication there's no
reason that's not yeah well
i mean how many altercations start over
some
stupid piece of content that has nothing
to do with anything and then it burrows
down to a deeper
issue anxiety or resentment and so you
know it's important
it's an intimate relationship with an
editor you know you're letting them get
their
their hands into your psyche to some
extent
yeah that makes sense um so for this
series
six books did you have the entire series
in your head when you started
or did you write the first book and then
you came up with the second and then you
came up with the third
would you have an outline or what it's
funny you say that i ha it took me
i was really afraid to start this series
i wrote i kept back burning it i wrote
another standalone first
and then another standalone i really
wanted to make sure that i had my grasp
of of something that would be of
enduring interest to me
and i had a rough shape of it it's an
ongoing series
you know so it's gonna it's gonna
continue you know as long as people are
are reading them i plan to write them
but this book prodigal son i mean so
so quick background um orphan acts taken
out of a foster home at the age of 12
trained to be an assassin but jack
his handler kept his moral compass
intact so i didn't want it to be that he
was trained to be an assassin
it was awful and abusive i wanted it
confusingly
to also be the best thing that ever
happened to him and so jack who takes
him under his wing actually loves him
he jack has trained other orphans and he
says to him at one point the hard part
isn't making your killer the hard part
is keeping you human
um and of course being a human and being
a killer are two trains on a collision
course so when we
when i opened the series evan has left
the program
you know the government he he doesn't
just know where the bodies are buried he
buried
most of them so the government wants him
dead he's got a lot of dangerous
information in his head
and he's on the run um but while he's on
the run he has an encrypted phone
and the number is one eight five five to
nowhere which anyone can call you can
see what happens and he answers it
and it's only for people who are in
hopeless situations
basically being terrorized by bullies or
tyrants and they have nowhere else to
turn and then he helps them
and when i sold orphan x the first book
i said one of these days
so here's evan never knew his parents
grew up in the system
series of foster homes i said one of
these books the phone's gonna ring
and the person on the other end is gonna
say evan it's your mother
and that's the story of prodigal son um
oh my god
so that's how prodigal son opens and
what's funny is
as i pitched this when i sold the series
when i first saw that i said it's not
gonna be book three or four
but that's gonna happen at a point when
i feel comfortable enough with the
character
to dive back into his past and we don't
know if she's his mom we don't know if
it's a ruse and she's pulling him out
for him to be assassinated
but this is the first book where i go
back into that world i go back into the
foster home and we see some of the
things that shape the hero who he is
today
and at the same time as much as it's
going back into the past
and more personal it's sort of exploding
the intriguing level of threat and
menace in the present day
that takes him all the way up to you
know the highest levels of power whether
it's
visionaries in silicon valley or the
military industrial complex and so it's
got this kind of weight counterweight to
it and i always had this book in my head
um that i wanted i was aiming at it for
from the beginning and i always knew i'd
get here
that's how you snatch the publishers in
you're like i've got this great idea but
it's six
books in yeah all i need is an
11 book deal but you know i was trying
to think about all the ways that news
stories and new ideas can pour into the
book and as someone who had written a
lot of standalones it was important to
me that there's a lot of tributaries
that could feed stories
so with evan you know the phone can ring
and
his other nickname is is the his other
alias of the nowhere man
he can answer the phone and go on a
mission to help someone in need
or his past the orphan acts the sort of
mythology of the program and the
government coming after him can be a
story
or a story can come in from all these
people surrounding him
as he's trying to kind of integrate or
or at least
live among ordinary people where he
lives in in you know castle heights the
residential tower that he lives in so
he's surrounded with ordinary people and
he's trying to help ordinary people
and i think of it like because of how he
was raised
off the grid he was trained in
hand-to-hand combat he was
drown proof he was taught foreign
languages and etiquette it was this sort
of
blue-collar renaissance training for
strategic survival
when operating but because of all that
he's always on the outside it's like
he's got his face up to the glass
looking in at ordinary people leading
ordinary lives
and he can never get there but what he
can do is he can intervene
and help those people who are being
terrorized by others
to reestablish the kinds of lives for
themselves with safety and intimacy
that he can never have for himself and
so he's sort of stuck in this
purgatorial landscape
did you get drown proof from navy seal
training
i did not i've not done drown proofing
but navy seals do
is that where you got the idea for him
though yeah
yeah they i mean they basically bind you
and they put your
head gear on they throw you in a pool
and then two guys jump in after you and
they beat on you and they pull your mask
off and they pull your water out
your uh your air out and then you cough
and sputter and
maybe drown or lose consciousness and
they haul you up and revive you it's all
training to not panic when you're under
water
men i guess women do that too right are
there women in navy seals
no i don't know anything
and she was like that that's for
insane people
pummel me while i'm drowning yeah that
sounds like a good time
[Music]
men
yeah wow uh so you said you don't have
an ending
do you have an ending if you needed one
of the whole series
yeah hmm are you just gonna leave people
like freaking game of did game of
thrones even have an ending i guess the
tv show kind of had an
ending but the books just gave up well i
think we're waiting on
waiting on more book um yeah i don't i
mean i have some notions of what would
happen but i hope
i hope it's far enough away that i
that i'm going to learn a lot between
now and then i mean that's what happens
is
it's i don't lock into too rigid a
structure i don't even do that for
individual books
i have my outline has to also live and
breathe and evolve as i'm writing
um because when i write i'm also
discovering more about the characters
and the plot and
different things are happening in terms
of their voices in fact one of my
favorite characters
is a 16 year old hacker named josephine
morales she goes by joey
and i first introduced her in hellbent
which was the third book and i was
planning to kill her at the end of that
book
um but she was so smart she's this tough
brilliant hacker she's a washout from
the orphan program she knows how to
fight she's tough as hell she's also
really vulnerable she's really labile
um and evan gets stuck watching her when
he least wants to like he's kind of
stuck with her as his charge
and in the course of that book i
realized that she was she was so much
fun to write she was so much funnier
than i am
in real time and she brought such a
different energy
and she brings out all these other sides
in evan i got to the end of the book and
i just couldn't kill her
and she's played a very prominent role
in you know in the series
in some ways she's she's the most
important secondary character in a lot
of ways to evan
and i just released a short story
featuring her
as the lead it's called the list um and
that's i just released that on kindle
and oh cool and in that one
evan is like a secondary character
supporting her
and so you know learning when i was
writing her and introducing her and
seeing how much color
and complexity she brought um
made me switch my you know i'm so glad i
didn't wind up killing her
it's so interesting talking about you
know we see so often people talk about
writing strong women characters right
it's almost become a trope and in some
ways it's
it's almost it can almost get boring
when women are just flattened
out to be only the strongest aspect
of like they always have the right line
they never get caught with anything one
of the things that that really struck me
when i've been thinking about writing i
love writing uh
female characters and there's there's a
whole host of them in orphan x
i'm always way more interested in
writing and i think it's more respectful
to think about writing complex
female characters instead of merely
strong because
that's what i try and do for male
characters right you don't just want
them to be
generically strong right like you know
the the sort of
dirk chin cleft to your rescue the
hearty
powerful male character doesn't have a
crack and so i try and always imbue
um all the characters primary secondary
despite gender race anything
with a lot of complexities so that so
that they're not two-dimensional
and that's something that is really on
display with joey because she's got
so much life and so much exuberance and
she makes a lot of mistakes and she
oversteps she's incredibly
um i like also having um
one of the things that's been really fun
in orphanax is
he's his sort of operational family of
people who are familiar with what he
does
they're all better than he is at one
thing you know one of the lines he's
told when he's trained is
you will learn something about
everything from people who know
everything about one thing
so tommy stojak is like his guns and
material expert is a way better sniper
than evan joey's a way better hacker
than evan
so there's a dynamic for me that i like
a lot where these other characters can
kind of make fun of him and undermine
him like he's slow to keep up
rather than having everybody who just
adores him where he's surrounded and
he's sort of the suave hero in a way
like james bond is
i like that he can get undercut i like
that the other characters in his
that he surrounds himself with are
better than he is at certain things
uh and i realized that's i like people
in real life who do that too
i don't like people who stick to their
own little dominant hierarchy where
everybody kind of worships them
and so that's gone in the world i've
created with him and joey really opens
that up because she can just be
relentless at him because she doesn't
care
she's 16 few things in the world are as
dangerous as a 16 year old girl
right that is very very very true uh one
of the things i found though the wonder
woman series got wrong
because i'm actually a pretty big fan of
woman wonder woman as i've said before
is
she's so one-sided it's
like nauseating to watch maybe it's
meant for younger kids or something
maybe it's just like a pg-13 film and
i'm not
that age anymore but i was like i guess
superman also kind of has that issue a
little bit
maybe they're just too invincible and
it's like well we know how this is gonna
turn out like who's gonna come along
here they're just too good that's why
batman is so cool and the punisher
that's why punisher is so cool
yeah i mean i think that's what draws me
to those characters is there's a lot of
of darkness there you know and it's
funny because
one of the things i explore in prodigal
son is
there's some a.i the military technology
revolves around ai that's trying to
figure out how to put a moral adapter in
some ways
uh into killing machinery so that humans
can be removed from
the guilt or the strain of having to
actually kill people and so it's this
very interesting thing we've seen this a
lot in discussions in drone warfare
that people get further and further
removed from combat but evan
bears the cost of the assassinations
that he committed he committed a decade
of assassinations
for the us government when he was in
deep cover right they're all
unsanctioned they're all illegal under
international law
but there's this really interesting
notion for me that the hero what a hero
has to do what we ask of
our soldiers what we ask of our police
officers
is to bear the terrible cost of the
responsibility and
you know the guilt and the horror if
when necessary taking another human life
and that that sort of pain and trauma is
almost a necessity because if we remove
that from human consideration
war just gets too easy to wage there's
no stakes
and so a lot of what i'm writing about
with with evan
there's a lot of things that that came
to fruition i think when i was writing
batman and i was thinking about this
character i wanted to write
the balance between perfection and
intimacy right that's something bruce
wayne
can't ever kind of get right the more
perfect you are the fewer people are in
your life people are messy
right people are complex people screw up
your schedule
right people get in your way and so you
can't have both
um you need to figure out a balance
and so that's something that batman was
always dealing with that's something i
wanted evan to contend with too
is he's trying to kind of crack his way
towards dealing with
this complexity of like i said the
strange language of intimacy how do you
interact with other people
but if the more that he does that the
more vulnerable he is because it cracks
out of this sort of
meticulous assassin set of rules for his
life so he's trying to move from one set
of rules for life to another
is that thing you said about drones and
about potentially trying to make them
make moral decisions
is that based in reality or is that just
something that's based in reality a lot
is horrifying yeah they're trying to
program moral adapters
you know um the problem is
it's just you know we you see as well
with drone operators where they'll go
into a you know
kind of a freestanding building like a
trailer in the desert in
arizona right drone warfare you kill
people
you leave you go home you drive through
starbucks and you go home to your wife
and your kids it's bizarre it's
the asymmetrical aspect is crazy and
there's there's a lot of
trauma and weight to that still but
we're trying it's almost like we're
trying to distance it
sebastian younger wrote a fascinating
book about this um about how the rates
of ptsd
have increased ever more drastically for
our soldiers coming home obviously he
corrects for the fact of reportage
because
in world war ii it's not like ptsd was
something that people were studying as
much but even correcting for that
and one of the you know one of the
thesis that he puts forth is that
society has gotten increasingly we've
got increasingly removed from each other
so for a lot of people they would go to
war and there's part of that that speaks
to ourselves you're in you're in like a
hunter-gatherer
sized tribe right you're eating and
hunting and gathering and you're
covering each other's back and there's
something in that that speaks almost to
your dna even though it's it's in a
wartime condition and horrible things
can happen but but you're in a pack in a
way that we're almost designed to be
and with world war ii you know men men
and women
mostly men world war ii but soldiers
i'll just say
came home and there was parades there
were rituals to reintegrate them and
then they went off to their
rotary club they went off to their
bowling league they went off to their
men and women's church groups right
whatever it was
and so there's all these smaller tribes
and senses of community and we've we've
gotten so removed from our
the rituals of of our kind of
evolutionary design now that you have
soldiers coming back and they're in a
house with two kids
and a wife or husband and everyone's
kind of on their phone and
it's completely dislocating you know
based on coming from this tight-knit
group of people who are all covering
each other's interests
and so as as we get more alienated
in terms of society we're seeing the
rates of ptsd go up because it's not
necessarily contingent just on what you
saw it's not like
you know each foot of blood-drenched
sand and iwo jima
was any more or less pleasant than what
we're seeing in kandahar
right yeah i haven't thought about that
it's also the switchover and that's
that's definitely a problem i mean
that's certainly
a problem i have being on my phone and
things being isolated
and then there's covid which is just
isolating so
we definitely have that issue as a
society yeah coming home and everyone
being on their phone that would just be
absurd right
because naturally we're supposed to be
more hunter-gatherer
and have everyone's interests in mind
and know a bunch of people and talk to a
bunch of people and be around a bunch of
people this isolation thing
can't possibly obviously isn't good for
people regardless of whether or not they
go to war
that's right okay so you
worked i remembered and i wanted to
bring this up
i think it was a punisher book and i
think you
wrote it when i was eight or something
like
ridiculously young to be tortured by an
adult
but you're like i'm like michaela i
wrote you into this was it the punisher
it was a fool killer it was another
character in
the marvel max world called fool killer
yeah i got we've got to get you that
page
you should have that page somewhere i
want that page
your dad's nickname for you was snert
right and so i had a woman in
on an airplane who would and it was
endlessly um
yammering and i i called her rosalind
snurs
and she was talking so much and
aggravating my my
an assassin character i was dealing with
got got stuck on a seat next to her and
she's sort of overflowing her seat
and i had her talking so profusely
because you were you were a bit of a
talker you know
and so she's rosalyn smear was talking
so much that her air her air bubble the
dialogue bubble was actually crushing
him down in the seas
and finally he had enough so he took her
and i think he executed her in the
bathroom of the airplane
and so i was very pleased in a toilet
yeah he might have drowned her in the
toilet
she drowned her in the toilet
well you know there's a few people that
i know that i could do that with
that do that to their their
eight-year-old daughter who i
you know was fond of at the time and
that the parents and daughter would be
just delighted rather than offended
so that worked out well but you and your
dad love that
that was pretty funny i gotta say i was
looking to be like
some attractive woman and then it was
just this giant woman who talked all the
time and then was drowned in a toilet
and i was like
okay that's still kind of funny i would
like that page
we'll figure that out we got to get that
to you yeah far
a far cry from the uh the the diet
meat eating expert and and uh fitness
guru yeah rosalind snur was not matching
your
your uh maybe in the yammering
there's some yammering there's still
some yammering i keep it
i keep it slow though when the
interviews when there's someone like you
and then you're doing the yammering
that's true a lot of your money
okay greg i need to i need to end this
uh thank you so much for coming on
and i would definitely recommend
checking out this series orphan acts
series
but also um also the books before that
there was
one about cults that was so
good uh what was that called it's called
the program
the program that was so good that taught
me so much about cults so
that one orphan x uh greg where can
people find you online
at gregorwitz.nas i'm on twitter under
the wildly innovative handle at greg
horowitz
you know facebook instagram so i'm i'm
i'm sort of around and i'm out on
virtual
tour right now um hitting different
bookstores and
i brought in my mixed martial arts
fighting consultant to one we mix
martinis at another so there's some
pretty fun events going up to try and
make it a little bit more lively in
during the pandemic yeah well thanks for
coming on again
great to see you back
you